you know beginning last October here we
are but it's about nine months later and
you sort of put this the story of this
idea out into the world and and and I
can sort of see the impact that you guys
have already had can you talk about the
impact that you've had and did you
anticipate this many people rallying
behind what you guys are doing it's
interesting I mean because you know tiny
houses have been really popular in the
media especially in the last sort of
year you know and and that's something
that I don't really even think we
expected when we first started this
project you know it's not like we were
like oh tiny houses are really hot let's
do something about that it was really
kind of grew out of you know what was
going on in our own lives and we didn't
even realize sort of how big the
interest was and the movement was until
probably until sort of around the time
you were doing our Kickstarter campaign
and so I think we've been really lucky
in that respect you know in the timing
of it and you know that's sort of what
mean one of the reasons that we were
able to kind of take the leap and say
okay let's you know put more work into
this in- feature is because we felt like
this is an important story that people
are feeling drawn to and people want to
hear for whatever reasons and we kind of
like we've come this far we can't not
tell the full story so in terms of
impact um you know sort of hard to gauge
I think your impact sometimes as a
filmmaker because it's sort of a
nebulous thing and we haven't actually
been released our film yet but because
we did Kickstarter and because we've
been trying to get sort of grassroots
support we've put a lot of things out
there and we have blog and we have been
on a lot of other blog as a future and
things so so I think that's all unusual
for a lot of documentaries i don't think
maybe more and more but having
traditionally gotten so much out there
before they even had a film and but the
what so anyways it's hard to gauge what
impact that's been just from it in in
terms of you know this person made this
change in their life because of that
because we don't notice that people can
know about a project
but where it hits home for me is that I
actually had a few friends who now how
are like thinking about doing something
similar or shared with me we were
visiting a friend here the other day who
just just bought a house in LA but
before he about a house he wasn't
finding anything you liked and he was
you know doing a bunch of research and
like kind of drawn up plans to build a
tiny house because he came and visited
ours and so when I hear things like that
I'm like oh wow this does have some
impact people's lives and it's pretty
exciting you know and I think speak you
know if I could speak up for both of us
here we have had some opportunities to
share the project with kind of you know
like like first graders and also the
bioneers conference came out to the
building site in Colorado and so moments
like that are actually I think saw my
favorite parts when we're able to share
it with people who are really excited by
the whole thing yeah little kids are fun
because they're kind of like oh my god
this is possible like you're a grown-up
and this is my dream living my dream
which is really cool you've impacted us
and Dave will tell you that I've talked
about tiny houses now you know actually
uh this is really exciting we just found
out the last few days an uncle of mine
and I had a lot of uncles but one of
them is that is a urban planner in Idaho
and he's organizing the Idaho region and
regional and urban planners Association
conference or whatever and it's like
architects planners and people who are
in a position to actually like you know
make changes in their cities and stuff
in terms of the housing codes and he's
really excited about project and wants
us to come screen it there this fall and
maybe host some sort of etonics session
and I'm saying this just because I think
that is what I'm most excited about is
to get it in front of people who are in
the position to make make some changes
you know in society and and it started
getting us thinking about you know we
have a friend who we showed the film to
who runs a nonprofit and his first
question was okay so you made this film
what's your plan for it
afterwards in terms of you know having
to make a difference and and so now I
think when this position were like oh
we're kind of nearing the end of this
film how are we going to use it to make
an impact in and so I'm really excited
about doing things like that i'm taking
it to these types of conferences for
people who are in the position to do you
know something about this issue yeah i
mean there's just like the personal
downsizing level and there's also kind
of that the bigger you know the building
codes and you know the kind of more
societal things that can change his
balls so yeah so it works I did to try
to you know create some sort of momentum
kind of the film and watching one of Jay
schaeffer's videos he said when he first
heard that there was red tape around
tiny homes just the mere fact that there
was like I guess quote civil
disobedience around it made him want one
at that point and that was part of his
turning point so maybe they'll be a
whole movement of people that just
really want to challenge the status quo
in that sense but yeah
you